identify each number in the left column
with its opposite in the right column
with its opposite in the right column
and they talk about opposites these are
all integers they're really just talking
about the essentially the negative of
that number the counterpart of that
number that's on the other side of the
number line it's an equal distance away
from zero so for example when we're
looking at 3 its opposite its opposite
in this context so we have zeros here 3
is 3 to the right of 0 3 to the left of
0 is negative 3 so we could say 3 and
let's look for a negative 3 so those two
guys are opposites we could I'll just do
them in the same color it'll get messy
if I draw lines now let's do 100 well we
just have to look for the negative of a
hundred so we have a hundred and then we
have negative 100 right over here and we
have 12 let me do this in orange which
take the negative of it which is going
to be negative 12 sitting right over
there and then we have negative 55 well
the opposite or the negative of negative
55 is going to be positive 55 it's its
counterpart so it is positive it is
positive 55 then the opposite of
negative 3 or its counterpart this is a
negative counterpart to look for the
positive counterpart or the negative of
negative 3 we could think of it that way
the negative of negative 3 is positive 3
almost done
running out of colors I'll use this blue
color opposite of negative 5 it's
positive counterpart since this guy is
negative is going to be positive 5
positive 5 and then 21 negative 21 is
right over here right over here that's
its counterpart and then homestretch
negative 12 that's hard to read that
yellow let me do it in let me do it I'm
running out of dark colors so we have
this negative 12 right here it's we have
to look for its positive counterpart
since this is negative and that's going
to be positive 12 and we're done